don't start putting money into things
that you don't understand if you can't
explain it if you don't understand the
company you understand what you're
buying into don't buy it this is why i
don't buy cryptocurrency i don't buy
real estate people ask me about real i i
don't like real estate
i don't like it
uh i i know it's a massive path to
wealth uh
my friends like grant cardone and a
bunch of other people are like hardcore
in the real estate great i love it it
can definitely work i'm not down on the
on the idea i just don't
i don't like it i don't want to learn it
it's not interesting for me so i'd
rather invest my money elsewhere same
thing for cryptocurrency i don't i don't
understand it i get the concept but i
don't know which one's going to win i'm
not invested enough into it i haven't
learned could i yes am i interested no
so this is a challenge like if you're
just going off buying bitcoin because
it's hot you're gonna lose a ton of
money like you might get lucky and win
but you're basically just playing the
lottery